wait Audrey stop don't use that I
thought you liked to spells mistakes
happen don't they Audrey we don't mean
to single you out but we feel like you
to understand where we're coming from
you probably didn't notice any
inconsistencies when you were trying to
take over auradon but we spotted dozens
of them and we're about to reveal them
one by one but don't worry these
mistakes won't ruin your reputation in
any way like many other movies
descendants 3 has a handful of mistakes
that can be both easy and challenging to
spot we're about to reveal them all so
keep watching you like a prince mouth
how about a knight in shining armor 20
Knights the basket of pears the queen of
mean acts on impulse if she gets mad she
curses whoever offended her and if she
wants answers to questions whoever is
next to her she always gives them what
she thinks she deserves
Chad charming might be a follower but he
never betrayed Audrey's trust right
before Audrey locks Chad in a closet she
questions him and throws a glass bowl at
his head
but before she does this she empties out
the pear bowl on the table at first
there's a total of 5 pairs on the table
but when the camera cuts back to Audrey
there are only 3 pairs left
Dizzy's outfits at the very beginning of
d3 the villain kids put on quite the
show alongside the core 4 they dance do
wicked acrobatics and show off their
true colors despite showing us some
awesome moves something bizarre happens
to dizzy during this musical number we
Percy dizzy wearing a long dress made
out of patchwork but then a few seconds
later we see her wearing an entirely
different outfit how did dizzy managed
to switch outfits so quickly this is the
most fashionable mistake we've ever seen
Mouse powers another mistake we couldn't
help but notice has everything to do
with mouths when a tease tries to escape
through the barrier then Jay and Carlos
try to stop him but he blasts them with
his Ember this causes mal to transform
into a dragon and take on her dear old
dad but Hades ends a blast
her too and according to mal he was
draining all of her powers so why is it
that mouse powers didn't take a hit
throughout the film this is more of an
inconsistency than a mistake but it's
puzzling nonetheless the security guard
another inconsistency we couldn't help
but notice occurs when Audrey goes to
the Museum of cultural history Audrey
doesn't have any magical powers of her
own yet somehow she manages to put the
guard to sleep with zoom on the loose we
find it very unlikely that the guard
chose to take a snooze Audrey obviously
put the guard to sleep before cutting
the security cameras but how did she do
this it just doesn't make any sense
she also opened the museum's gates
without laying a finger on them protect
the crown not the scepter but Audrey's
magical touch isn't the only strange
thing that happens at the Museum
everything from the Queen's crown to
Cinderella's glass slippers two genies
lamp is protected by security glass but
when it came to Maleficent scepter
nothing was shielding it from Audrey's
grasp this is super off-putting
considering the scepter is a super
dangerous weapon Janes birthday cake
descendants three managed to make us
feel an array of emotions and one of
those was jealousy who else wanted to
grab a piece of Jane's birthday cake but
couldn't well you're not alone luckily
dizzy and Celia were able to steal a
piece from Jane's birthday cake before
Carlos had the chance to give it to her
we clearly see that a single piece of
cake is missing but when the camera cuts
to dizzy and Celia eating cake they each
have their own piece and plate so why is
it that there was only one piece missing
from the cake the cupcake once audrey
gets her hands on the crown in the
scepter she doesn't waste any time she
crashes Jane's party and starts picking
on everyone in her path does that make
you sad does it just ruin everything
she even craps a cupcake out of
someone's hands and throws it away now
that's just cruel where we the only ones
who notice that audrey grabbed the
cupcake backwards and yet didn't have
any frosting on her hand once you
chucked it tell us if you noticed this
mistake in the comments below
watch your back Carlos do you like a
prince
how about a knight in shining armour 20
Knights one of our favorite scenes from
descendants three is the metal knight
fight this is when the BK's truly learn
how to work together at one point during
the fight Carlos loses his sword there's
a knight right above him who's ready to
strike so Celia saves the day by sliding
a shield Carlos's way but for some
strange reason the knight never strikes
Carlos lillas puts the shield up that
nothing happens then he slides away on
it was this a huge mistake on the
Knights part VK day is here we all know
that mal is a talented spray paint
artists but during the good to be bad
musical number we see mal making a huge
mistake she's supposed to be spray
painting BK day on the door of a barn
but it just didn't look believable
clearly mal was just pretending the
spray paint old hag now Audrey may be a
lot of things but humorless is not one
of them she turns mal into an old hag at
the beginning of d3 you think Ben will
love you now you old hag forcing mal and
her friends to return to the Isle mouths
back is curved and she can hardly walk
yet somehow she manages to squeeze into
her VK outfit and write a motorcycle
that just doesn't make any sense did you
notice anything we didn't sound off in
the comments thank you for watching the
things don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to our Channel we'll catch
you next time
[Music]